I am not sure whether we really have a
strong need for hard data in soft
aspects of human improvement we need
hard data in terms of measuring skills
of course especially in math reading
mastering of computers digital
technologies more generally and so on so
these are the kind of hard measurable
aspects of human capacity
but then there are ways in which one can
stimulate creativity and are not very
easily defined in data let me give an
example in Slovenia we have a very good
network of musical schools and there are
many people young people who are
learning to to play various musical
instruments and I think the overall
effect of this doesn't depend on
anything measurable but really on the
energy of the mothers of children to
make sure that their children go to
musical schools at the right age and
that they they learn now I have been
president for five years and I have been
visited many small places in Slovenia
talked to musical school directors and
mothers and so on and I have seen how
important this motherly energy is for
the learning of music at a young age of
course many children are not talented in
the in this direction and of course they
they may even have some traumatic
experience as a result but on the other
hand the overall effect of this is that
we have pretty good a generation of
young musicians in Slovenia and that has
to do with something which is really
very difficult to measure I would like
to propose that all governments
stimulate everything that has to do with
creativity and it starts often with
something which is really very simple
for example when I visited schools as
president I often said to the teachers
and to steal the
I said well you know you are usually
told to be diligent but I'm telling you
be creative
diligence per se is not enough diligence
may be good but not sufficient so please
teachers teach your students to be
creative invent something in your own
method of work with your group of
students which would stimulate their
creativity now in Slovenia which is part
of the Central European educational
tradition this is not unimportant
because that tradition has been for
centuries based on a kind of a top-down
model of Education which still exists
and therefore there is a need to
deliberately inject the idea of
creativity into the educational process
I would very much like that to expand
but I have seen since I lived in the
United States for 13 years as well and
my daughter went to school in New York
that the American tradition is different
there I think much more effort and much
more emphasis is put on individual
talent of student stimulation of talent
can do approach optimism and all these
things and of course that educational
tradition I find quite beneficial
something that we in Europe have to
learn from and perhaps develop
creativity by using the techniques of
Education which put creative elements
more at the center